[Music]
right now somewhere in the universe a
giant star is detonating
[Music]
creating a huge cosmic explosion called
a supernova
supernovas are a big giant dramatic end
to a star's life
All Stars die but only the biggest go
out with a bang
for a Star to go supernova we think it
has to be at least eight times more
massive than our sun it's so easy to
think of our son as this incredibly
gigantic thing
but our sun is absolutely tiny compared
to some of the giant stars in the sky
we can see some of these giant stars
with the naked eye
10th brightest in the night sky is a red
super Giants around 15 times the mass of
the sun
Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice is so big that if you were
to place it in our own solar system it
would stretch to the orbit of Jupiter
this is one of the biggest beasts in the
Galaxy it's a star also that is on the
verge of death
metal juice is less than 10 million
years old
but this huge star's days are numbered
it's ready to blow
[Music]
and when it does we'll see a region of
Sky brighten for 14 days until it's
nearly as bright as a full moon
it is going to be one of the most
spectacular shows in history
[Music]
and it could happen at any moment I mean
this is the thing I often stand outside
in my yard in the winter time I look up
at Orion and I see Beetlejuice and I'm
like explode
so what will make Beetlejuice go
supernova to understand a giant star's
death we need to understand it's life
from the day it's born until the day it
dies a star's life is a constant battle
gravity is pulling in and energy pushing
out
the interior of a star is fusing
countless Atomic nuclei together
atoms are ramming into each other
getting very very close
if they get close enough they'll
actually stick and form a larger atom
every second a giant star fuses seven
and a half billion tons of hydrogen that
amount of energy is roughly equivalent
to about 100 billion atomic bombs per
second
that's a big ass explosion
this explosive energy threatens to blow
the star apart
but the star's own massive gravity keeps
the lid on
everything in the universe is a fight
force of gravity
gravity pressure or energy
every single star in the sky even our
own sun is an incredibly Dynamic
Battleground in many ways stars are an
explosion that are actually too big to
explode gravity holds it together
this battle between these two opposing
forces determines the life and death of
the star and this is where Size Matters
the more massive the star the more
gravity pushes Inward and the harder the
star has to push outward to keep itself
alive
very massive stars are like stars on
steroids
they have a lot of fuel to burn they're
so powerful that they use up their fuel
at a rapid rate
massive stars like Beetlejuice are giant
factories fusing lighter elements into
heavier ones
but the hard work doesn't start until
their final years
for around 90 percent of their life they
fuse hydrogen into helium but eventually
the hydrogen starts running out
in the core of a supergiant star there's
a sequence of fusion that goes from
lighter elements to heavier elements and
it gets faster and faster every step of
the way
the countdown to death Begins the inward
push from Gravity takes over raising the
temperature in the core
helium starts fusing into carbon
there's enough helium to last about a
million years but it too Runs Out
things start speeding up
carbon gets fused into neon that takes
about a thousand years neon fusing into
silicon that takes about one year once
it starts fusing silicon into iron that
takes one day
it gets more and more frantic it's it's
kind of like a cooking contest show
whereas the clock is running down
they're trying to do more and more
things and they get more and more
frantic until ding
time's up
the star is now in its Death Rows
once iron production has started the
clock is ticking towards the cataclysmic
end of this star
a giant ball of incredibly dense iron
forms in the middle of the dying Stars
core
this iron sphere is several thousand
miles across
unbelievably hot
it gets so hot there the temperature
almost becomes meaningless I mean we're
talking about a billion degrees in the
center of one of these Stars
this extreme heat is caused by Fusion
reactions more and more reactions create
heavier and heavier elements and with
each step less and less energy is
produced until iron is created
when you try to fuse iron nuclei
together that takes energy it doesn't
generate energy so once the core starts
to fuse iron it's basically stealing its
own energy
the growing iron core sucks more and
more energy from the Star gravity
continues pulling in overwhelming the
outward pressure from inside the star
[Music]
agrees
only a reaction to support the star
against the crush of gravity
with nothing left holding it up the star
is doomed gravity wins the edges of the
iron core collapse trillions of tons of
dense iron fall inward at a quarter of
the speed of light
the star has now less than one second
left to live
things start to fall apart
really quickly
or collapse is so fast that the outer
layers of the star don't even have time
to react they're just hanging there it's
kind of like Wiley Coyote when a cliff
collapses underneath him and he doesn't
even fall until he notices
the rest of the star collapses a
trillion trillion trillion tons of gas
hurdle inwards following the iron I
think the entire mass of
the sway in a split second everything
rushes into the middle
and that sets off the most dramatic
explosion in the universe
[Music]
the spectacular death blow can outshine
all of the stars in the galaxy
but there's a problem we still don't
fully understand how a collapsing ball
of iron and tons of falling gas create a
giant Fireball
how this collapsing core triggers a
massive explosion is one of the biggest
mysteries in astrophysics